right now you're racing for 23-11 that's
co-owned by michael jordan the other
owner denny hamlin can you kind of talk
about how serious mj is as an owner and
how serious he takes the sport
oh he's he's very serious very
professional very tuned in
and the times that i've been around him
you know i first was going through the
job interview he's like just pointing
straight at my heart he goes yeah we
never have to worry about you out there
driving because we know you drive from
your heart just like i play and the
people in the spirit of our race team
all feel that from mj the mj's still
that classic you play from your soul and
you play smart you play hard
and uh so it's a really cool atmosphere
racing for him and yeah the other day at
loudoun i was uh on a pole speed run
didn't quite get it i got third
and he gives me the whole like arms
emoji like what happened joke man he
choked
what's it like when you first meet
michael jordan check this out so
signing all the paperwork to get the
team
um registered for this season and on the
entry blank for the daytona 500
uh his name his signature is up there as
owner above mine my ass is cool you know
like
he signs the paperwork and i'm like wait
a minute
like the the light bulb above my head
went off i said i'm gonna go get a
michael jordan rookie card
and i'm gonna come up with a plan
to have him sign this you know i can't
go all fanboy right
yeah yeah but i came up with a plan
i talked to denny hamlin about it and i
said you know
i'm gonna give it to him and then i'm
gonna give him a pen
and i'm gonna have him hold the card
and then i get it back after we win
together okay and so when he opens
pretty cool he opened it up and he
unwraps he goes man you you paid a
pretty penny for this how much did you
pay i saw i can't tell you that oh yeah
yeah
jordan rookie cards are like they cost
like as much as like some real cars and
then he gave me the card back though
after we won so the trust came back
through
you